so cnbc has this host joe kernan who's
been around
a very very long time we've talked about
him before he's previously attacked me
on twitter
and he sometimes will do really cringy
interviews on cnbc some of which we've
covered in the past
and the last few days were no exception
to that
joe kernan invited on an independent
energy consultant
named allison silverstein to talk about
what happened
in texas with the storms and the power
outage
and it sort of seemed like joe kernan
was being
moderately reasonable during the first
part of the interview
but when alison silverstein starts to
assert her expertise
in a way that joe kernan doesn't like
for political reasons like for example
saying
even if we continue switching over to
renewable energy to green power
a week in winterize it can be resilient
it can work fine in all sorts of
different weather
it started going downhill slowly slowly
slowly you see the frustration build for
joe kernan
where at the end he ends up doing almost
like
the full prototypical unhinged
flat out climate science denial
bury your head in the sand type stuff so
we'll build to that we're going to pick
it up where allison silverstein is
explaining that
the reason the grid lost power
generation capacity was because
as we've now talked about many times
talked about it last week talked about
it earlier today
texas opted not to winterize
many elements of their electrical grid
including
coal natural gas and nuclear plants
and yes some wind turbines despite the
fact that they were advised to win to
rise
a decade ago when they had similar power
outages caused by
cold weather and alison silverstein also
criticizes
the isolated nature of texas's grid and
so let's
start there so that we're all on the
same page as to how this started going
in this bad direction for joe kernan
there was all of this happen because of
insufficient power plant
winterization this was a guideline it
wasn't mandatory
there was a huge chunk of the natural
gas supply for texas power plants that
froze up
both at the wellhead level at production
and in pipelines so
gas plants couldn't get the fuel that
they needed to run
ercot under forecast customer demand by
20
which means that they didn't have enough
generation ready to serve customer
demand that kept rising as the night got
colder and colder
and last er cuts a standalone grid so
they were unable to alleviate these
shortages by importing
gen electricity from outside from the
rest of texas
and that's a wonderful idea if you like
avoiding federal regulations but it's a
terrible idea if you like protecting
reliability
against disasters like this so that's uh
sort of sets up her view
and in the second part of this interview
it starts to go downhill even after joe
kernan
initially concedes that those initial
critiques of wind power
and frozen windmills weren't true alison
silverstein
makes clear that listen big picture even
if we switch over
more and more to renewable energy it can
be fine in the winter
it's okay and that's how it starts to
get wacky
well you pointed out that the i forget
what type of energy you caught but
the more conventional energy natural gas
and others that you talked about did
were affected by the cold just like you
know we're
you know initially certain people maybe
the governor
maybe uh you know people that that
aren't big
aren't big green new deal proponents
said well you know
the windmills froze and the sun went
down or went away so you didn't have
solar
or wind um that wasn't true
but because we now know that the the
conventional stuff was affected by
the cold as well but what about
renewables and and the future that we're
looking at
will will we be ready for
adverse weather events if we're uh if
we're much more
dependent on this this new age
renewable energy of course we will
and the the thing is what
grid reliability requires that you
understand the resources that you have
so joe starts to get a look of uh
on his face because alison silverstein
says
of course we will be ready for weather
events under a renewable energy system
and then by the end of it it's full on
climate denialism
with joe kernan repeating some of these
silly things oh oh they said it was
gonna get warmer but the warmer can make
it cooler and none of it makes sense and
it's all just
silly take a look and and um we can make
a bridge much more stable with more
efficiency
but i mean there have been cold spells
before in in texas
this was similar to one of what back it
how long ago was it about
35 2011. right i mean it's 2011.
in 1990 1990 as well so
you know i i mean it's it's kind of a
big leap
we did not implement all of the lessons
like
used to just be cold air from the arctic
now it's a polar
vortex caused by the warming so i i need
to see the
i need to see the peer-reviewed science
on the on on the uh
the warming causing the cold anyway
allison
so do i but the point is the atmosphere
the weather every kind of
weather is getting worse right and
and so we need to plan we need to plan a
system that suits
much more kinds of really horrible
weather
and part of part of improving
reliability in a different system
there's more transmission
thank you bye okay thank you alison we
appreciate it
so the takeaway here is that anything
short of total absolute simplicity in
the eyes of a committed climate denier
means that they can just write off the
entire thing as completely untrue
and of course you may know and we've
been reporting on this for
a decade at this point the climate data
on this has been understood for a very
long time many decades
what was originally sometimes called
global warming which is not
inaccurate when you talk about an
increase in global temperature
really it's climate change and it can
include
yes an overall warming of the earth it
can include
an overall warming of the oceans on
earth
which by throwing off the balance of the
environment
can cause acutely hot and cold spells
in individual places over periods of
many different years
that is understanding how climate and
weather are two different things
but joe kernan either doesn't get it or
doesn't want to get it
and takes any opportunity where nuance
is required to say oh give me a break uh
it's global warming which causes it to
be cold
oh it's a polar vortex come on guys it
must all just be completely fake
climate is the extended circumstances
over time and place the whole planet
might warm by two degrees
the oceans might warm by two degrees or
something hypothetically
and then in terms of weather that can
cause
lots of high temperature records and low
temperature records
in different places it could be extra
cold in places that are often warmer
you could have milder summers in places
that are typically hotter
you could have more hurricanes or
tornadoes or whatever drought
as another example and unfortunately
this is how much of the climate
denialism system works oh you used to
call it global warming
but now it's too cold in some places so
you change the name
checkmate liberals this is the level on
which they're operating
if the oceans are warming why is it so
cold in texas
checkmate liberals come on and
the saddest part of this is that that
type of of talking point that type of
denialism
is really well suited for the party of
anti-science
which has decried college education as
merely liberal indoctrination
for a decade now and although we're
making progress over time on more and
more people understanding reality more
and more people conceding that
yes human activity probably does play a
role in our changing climate it is a
very slow process
and in the meantime people like joe
kernan
can do a lot of damage by making the
progress on public opinion on this
even slower and that's exactly what he
is trying to do pathetic
we've seen this from joe kernan before
no indication he's going to stop anytime
soon